We are going to be
leaving the territory of--
some of you have had
high school chemistry.
We're going to be starting
to leave that territory
and get into some of the things
I've talked about before,
that you may have never seen.
So for example, today we'll be
talking about semiconductors
and what happens when you
take all these atomic orbitals
and you put them into a solid.
And then, by the end of the
week, we'll talk about metals.
And then next week, we're
going to talk about crystals.
So that's what's coming.
OK, now there's one
type of bonding--
Before we get into
semiconductors and solids,
there's one type of bonding
we covered but I didn't
put the stats up on the column.
So I just wanted to kind of
make sure that we finish that,
and that was hydrogen bonding.
And there's a little video--
you know, water,
we're not going to go
into all the amazing
properties of water.
But if you're interested,
this is a really cool website
that talks about all
the anomalies of water.
And many of water's
properties are anomalous.
And much of the reason for that
is the last type of bonding
we talked about,
intermolecular bonds
we talked about last Friday,
which is the hydrogen bond.
So remember our table, I just
wanted to fill out the table
because I didn't fill
out the table, right.
That's the type of bond.
And the model was some
kind of electronegative--
it was some kind of highly
electronegative atom.
Like a was oxygen or
nitrogen or fluorine.
So that you drew a lot of
charge off of that hydrogen
and you left it with a
really strong delta plus
so that it could then
bond to some other atom.
It might be the
same, by the way.
It was in the cases
that we talked about.
Actually, I'll just use the same
atom because we use HF and H2O,
so then it would
be the O or the F.
But it's to a lone
pair on that atom.
That was the hydrogen bond.
And the range of attraction is
in kilojoules per mole of bonds
is something like,
let's see, 10 to 40.
So it's pretty strong,
you know, compared
to some of the weaker
things like London,
the hydrogen bond
can be pretty strong.
And one of the examples
that is the classic example
would be
Hydrogen, hydrogen, there's
the hydrogen bond right there,
you see?
Hydrogen bond between another
oxygen with its hydrogens
as well.
Now, we talked about
how water is so special
because in the case of water,
not only do I have exactly two
hydrogens in each molecule that
have caused this strong delta
plus, but I've also
got two lone pairs.
So the numbers work.
In HF, that's also
a hydrogen bonded--
it can hydrogen bond
to itself, but I've
got three lone pairs on
each F and only one hydrogen
that I've taken that
charge away from.
So you still get the
hydrogen bonding,
but this is the
beautiful balance.
And there's a video showing
water bonded to each other.
Oh, there it is.
Because there's nothing like
just imagining what a hydrogen
bond looks like.
And so of course, a
hydrogen bond will--
OK, charges.
Oh, it's French.
[SPEAKING FRENCH] OK.
Oh, that's what it looks like.
Really, if you could
get down there,
it would be a ray of
a laser beam light.
It's a liaison hydrogene.
And there it is.
And this is what's
going on in the liquid.
They're kind of
seeing each other.
And they're talking.
But they feel this strong,
strong hydrogen bond.
And that's happening
all over the place.
And in a liquid, they are making
and breaking all the time.
Question?
STUDENT: Why do they separate?
Yeah.
Yeah, because--
well, it depends.
It depends.
It's a great question.
Why do they separate?
Well, they don't in ice.
So in ice, I mean,
you know, they can.
But in ice, it's a solid, so
they're sort of locked in.
And so in there, you're going
to have pretty much each water
molecule has four--
look at this.
It's you know from VESPR, right?
Four possible bonds.
You can make tetrahedral.
But there's actually
lots of ways
you can orient them in a solid.
There's many forms of
ice, 12 different ways
to make a solid of ice.
But see, here-- gesundheit.
So here in the liquid
at room temperature,
with the laser beams, they're
coming in and they're bonding,
but they have enough energy
to break the bond, too.
So they stick and they
unstick because there's
enough thermal energy in the
system to continuously break
them and remake them.
That's when it's a liquid.
When is it a liquid
versus a gas?
Right, the boiling
point, remember,
that is a proxy we
talked about last Friday.
That is a proxy for
the bonding strength
between these molecules.
If it's a stronger bonding,
then the boiling point
will be higher and higher.
Oh, water should have boiled
at a much lower temperature
if it didn't have this very
special hydrogen bond, which
is not a dipole-dipole.
People try to write the physics
of the hydrogen bond as 1
over r cubed.
That is not true.
That is not just as simple as,
it's another dipole-dipole type
interaction.
It's complicated.
Complicated.
Remember, we had covalent
bonds were complicated too.
So we're not going
to put a simple one
over r something dependence
for the hydrogen bond.
OK, good question.
OK now, all right, so that's
an intermolecular-- now
we're going to
move on to solids.
So that was our last
intermolecular interaction.
Oh, before I do,
there's actually
an example question I put there
that you could now answer,
which this is actually--
I just want to show
you the type of--
so we covered all these
intermolecular bonds.
Here's a question
from a quiz last year.
List the intermolecular forces
in each substance, methane,
and then you've got that CH3OH.
And then you've got the CH3CL.
And so you can do this
now because for methane
all you've got is London.
It's not a polar molecule.
All you've got is London.
There's no hydrogen bond.
But for CH3OH, do you
have hydrogen bonding?
Yeah, you do.
Because if you draw--
because you've got an H
that's had the charge taken
from it by oxygen, a highly
electronegative atom, and then
and then you've got lone
pairs on that same oxygen.
So you can hydrogen bond
and you've also got London.
All right, now is that it?
Is there anything else?
CH3OH.
What else?
Is there any other type of bond?
Well, the last question
you need to ask
is, is there a dipole
moment in the molecule?
Because if that molecule
had a permanent dipole,
then there is another type of
intermolecular interaction,
like we talked
about, dipole-dipole.
So you'd have three.
And for CH3CO, well there, you
also-- you know that for CH3CO,
you're going to have
a dipole moment.
Remember, we compared
dipole moments of molecules.
And if you have a diaper
moment in a molecule,
then that dipole moment can
talk to another dipole moment
and be interacting with it.
So that's a kind of bond.
And is that it?
London, London is always there.
It's always there.
We've also got
London, don't forget.
So you'd have dipole-dipole
plus London here.
Dipole-dipole London and
hydrogen, just London.
So this is the kind
of way I want--
and you might be able
to think about, well,
would a trend-- if
you think about,
like, OK well, if
a molecule just
has London, then what
does London depend on?
All right, well, it depends
on the polarizability
of the charge.
So that can be
something [INAUDIBLE]..
It depends on the size because
that tells you how much--
if I say, well, what about
SIH4 compared to CH4?
Which is going to be
more strongly bonded?
You can answer that
because you know
the only force there is London.
And you know for London, it's
how much contact area you have
is going to be one
of the factors.
The more contact area, the
more chances these things
can get close
enough and polarize.
And then polarizability
would be the other.
All right, now we're
going on to solids.
Now, the big picture
is pretty awesome.
If you look at the
big picture, we
have done the
electronic structure
of atoms and molecules.
So we've gone through
and we've worked our way
through the Bohr atom, the
atomic model, quantum numbers,
Aufbau, what happens when
you go from one electron
to many, and octet stability,
which is Lewis and Vesper.
We have also now talked about
how molecules come together
in different ways, how the atoms
come together in the molecule,
and how the molecules come
together in different ways.
Dipole-dipole, London
dispersion, hydrogen bonding.
And then there's these
forms of aggregation,
gas, liquid, and solid.
And of course, we're
excited about this.
So I put my little emoji
there, because that's
what we're going to do now.
We're actually going to take--
we talked a little bit
about solids already,
but now we're going to take the
electronic structure that we've
built up, these orbitals.
And we're going to make
solids out of them.
So this is the week where these
are the next two weeks, right,
where we're going to
talk a lot about solids.
And this week, this
week we're going
to do the electronic structure.
And next week, we're
going to do atoms.
So that's our plan.
And next week Friday, we're
going to break a bunch of stuff
with parents.
So this week we're [INAUDIBLE].
What do electrons do in solids?
Next week, how do atoms
arrange in solids?
And together, that gives
us so much understanding
of how chemistry effects
properties in solids.
So that's the big picture.
Now, here's the thing,
why does that matter?
Well, because so many
properties can vary by so much
depending on what I just said.
How does chemistry affect
properties in solids?
Well, it's complicated,
but look at this variation.
28 orders of magnitude of
connectivity, electrical
conductivity.
28 orders of magnitude,
that's a lot of zeros.
[INAUDIBLE]
These are the electrical
conductivities
of different atoms,
different materials.
And you can see that it's going
to depend on what you have,
but it's also going to depend
on-- so that's the chemistry.
But it's also going to
depend on the bonding.
It's going to depend on how
the electronic structure comes
together.
And it's going to depend on
how the atoms come together.
That is what will explain
28 orders of magnitude.
That is a lot of variation.
So we start by thinking about
how electrons see these solids.
That's how we're going to start.
Now, the thing is that
these good old days
of molecular orbital
theory are going to end.
They're going to
have to end today.
No, they're not ending for
like quizzes and exams.
Don't forget about them.
But we've got to move
on because this is just
two atoms, two atoms.
But what happens when
we have like a solid?
How many atoms do we have?
We've got a lot.
So let's go-- we'll go here.
OK, now, if you think about
that picture, that was our--
I'm going to take 1s orbitals.
And let's just think
about this for a second.
If we take 1s
orbitals and you have
two atoms that come
together, well, they're
going to do just what
you see there where
you've got your 1s and your 1s.
I'm not even going
to fill these out,
and they're sigma
and sigma star.
And so that would be like two
1s orbitals that I have either--
OK, so up here, I took one.
It was a positive
and I subtracted one.
And here, I took
one and I added one.
And remember, this
gave us this and this.
And this gave us the
bonding orbital, right?
Bonding, anti-bonding.
It all came from LCAO.
LCAO is the linear combination
of atomic orbitals.
That's the theory
we use to build
up our [INAUDIBLE] theory.
But now, we've got
to go a lot further.
So I'm going to--
because I don't
want to keep adding things here
and here, it gets complicated.
I'm trying to find the MOs for
more, and more, and more atoms
because I've got to put a
whole lot into my solid.
So I'm going to write
them just on one side.
If I write the two
here like that,
and that would be
sigma and sigma star,
then you know what
I'm talking about.
I'm taking the two
and I'm combining them
in two different ways.
But what if I had three?
Well see, if I had three--
so I've got three
s orbitals now.
So if I've got three s orbitals,
then if you think about it,
I could also add them like that.
That would be a very
nice bonding orbital.
If you add them,
you see that they're
going to have the same kind
of really nice bonding.
But I can also subtract
one in the middle.
And if I did that--
so I had a plus,
minus, plus there.
So those are the signs,
plus s, minus s, plus s.
Then you can see that in-between
those, as I add these together,
you have nodes.
So this is not going to look
like a very happy bonding
situation.
I'm going to have
something in there
and then something in there.
That's what that's going to
look like as I bring them closer
and try to add them.
I made two nodes here.
Well, there's one other
way you could do this.
And we know that the number
of molecular orbitals
has to equal the number
of atomic orbitals.
We know that.
So there's one
more that we mean,
because I started
with three s's.
And you can kind of see that.
You can see that because
if I had a plus and a plus,
if I had done it that way
or maybe the other way,
maybe this was
over there, but you
see I got a little bonding
going on in here between them.
And I got an anti-bonding there.
It's almost like it
kind of cancels out.
So you can imagine that
that combination of s
orbitals, if I add and
subtract them this way,
it's going to be somewhere
right in the middle.
Maybe not so bonding,
maybe not so anti-bonding.
OK, good.
All right, well let's do four.
So if I had four, if
I started with four--
this is like four
hydrogen atoms, let's say,
although I'm not filling it yet.
But so four 1s orbitals.
Well now you see,
I could do this.
I can add them all up and get
this super awesome bonding
state.
I could also alternate
them so that everything
is anti-bonding.
Look at that.
These are going to cancel
as you bring them together
and you're going to get
anti-bonding, anti-bonding.
But there's also two other
options that are in between.
Right here, I can add
2 and then subtract 2.
And you can see, these
are both negative.
And as they come
together, they're
going to overlap
constructively, so will these.
But in the middle
here, they're going
to be kind of
destructive interference.
And so you're going to have
this one node in between.
But in general, you
can imagine, this
will be more bonding
than anti-bonding,
so we draw it down
below the middle.
Whereas up here, you could
also imagine something
like this, where you
start with a plus
and you put two minuses in
there and a plus over there.
I'm just adding and subtracting.
I'm just taking LCAO
theory and moving it
to more than two orbitals.
OK, so now you can
actually understand this
from a number of nodes, right?
This is like three nodes.
This is two nodes over there.
This is one node.
And zero nodes.
This is exactly
the kind of thing
we talked about already,
but for only two orbitals.
Now we're just
continuing it along.
OK, you can see why the good
old days are over, because see,
now we've got to
jump this up a level.
And we've got to think,
how many s orbitals
do I have in a typical
piece of matter?
How many do you think?
Take a guess.
Roughly?
Take a chunk of
hydrogen this big.
How many atoms do I have?
A mole, exactly.
That's why we
invented the mole, so
that we could count big numbers
by just saying 1, 1 mole.
But if I have a mole,
then I've got like 10
to the 24th of these.
I just went to four.
But it just keeps on going.
So [INAUDIBLE].
So here is like, OK,
1, orbital of atom.
Boy, I labeled that well.
2, bonding, anti-bonding
orbitals of molecules.
And then you see, OK, there's 3.
There's 4, 5.
Then you keep on going.
OK, they got a
little tired and then
they wrote 30, 30 orbitals.
30 is still way, way far away.
But if you had 30s
orbitals, you might still
be able to kind of see
these lines discretely.
Remember, this is energy space.
There might actually--
remember, like,
these energies are
really important,
the lines between the deltas.
But if you have a mole,
if you have a mole,
it looks like one
continuous set of lines.
These don't really
look discrete anymore.
These don't look discrete.
And so if you have a mole of
atoms, so if you have a solid,
we call that collection
of orbitals that
are all stuck in here a band.
We call that a band.
OK, so if I take--
Now, I'm not going to
draw 10 to the 24th.
10 to the 24th s orbitals.
But pretend, pretend that
that's what I have here.
Then what happens?
What I do is I form a continuum
of states, a continuum
of levels for those electrons.
And this, they're
so packed together,
we don't even draw
them as lines.
We can't.
So this is called the 1s band.
Oh, band.
It's a band.
It's a band of states.
It's the 1s band.
Now, there are some
important rules
that are really just the same
but we follow them here too.
And so I want to emphasize them.
We've already learned
them for molecules.
They holds for bands and solids.
All right, so now, for example,
let's think about this.
Each of these orbitals could
occupy how many electrons?
Two.
So I have two electrons
for each s orbital, s orb.
Well, you know, if you think
about that, then for n atoms,
and here what did I
say, 10 to the 24.
Because there is one s orbital
that comes from each atom.
So for n atoms, then I
would have 2n electrons
can go into the one s band.
So if I have--
that makes sense, right?
Because I had two for each
orbital, and I had that many.
So if I know how many atoms I
have that make up this solid,
then that's how many electrons
that band can have in it.
All we did is go from the atomic
orbital picture to the solid
to the mole.
OK, why am I saying that?
Because filling is
incredibly important
And it happens in the
same way-- just like it
was so important for
molecular orbitals,
it's also critical for bands.
So filling is like MOs.
It's just like in MOs,
start from lowest energy.
Then fill up.
So you know, if you
think about this,
if I had-- now I'm
going to actually say,
well, OK, I made the one s band
by combining these orbitals.
Now I'm going to
see what I have,
which tells me how to fill it.
Now I have hydrogen. So
if this is the one s band
and I have hydrogen, hydrogen
has, for each hydrogen,
I've got one electron.
But I just said that
in the one band,
for each atom I could
have put two electrons.
So you know if this is made
of hydrogen, it's half filled,
which is exactly what
that picture shows.
That's the filling.
You see it's filled half way.
The band is filled halfway.
It's like the MO
picture, but it's not
because I've made a
continuous band out of it.
So instead of putting
lines here, lines there,
and then occupying
them with arrows,
I fill them up with 10
to the 24-ish electrons.
So we fill bands up like that.
And we know that
it's half filled
because it's hydrogen.
Another thing
that we know is
that the energy--
remember this?
This is also important.
That energy is related to
interaction and overlap.
This is something we talked
about, interaction and overlap
of the orbitals.
How much does that band
go up and down in energy?
This is something
we've talked about.
How much that band
goes up and in energy,
it's just like in
the H2 molecule.
One s, one s,
sigma, sigma, star.
How far apart are
sigma star and energy?
Well, it depends on the
interaction strength
and the overlap
between those orbitals.
The same is true in solids.
Same is true in solids.
So what is the
width of that band?
How spread out
over energy is it?
OK, so those are
some ground rules.
Now, what else can we say?
OK, so there's the
absolute least bonding
state, anti-bonding, all the
way up there, the most bonding.
And then you've got
almost infinite number
of possibilities in between.
But the thing is that filling
determines the properties.
You can't just know the
bands or the band structure,
as it's called.
But you have to
know the filling.
And when you have a
situation like this--
so let's write this down.
When you have partial
filling, partially
filled band is a metal.
And I will talk about
metals on Friday.
So we will come
back to that concept
and the electronic structure
of metals on Friday.
But today, I want to talk about
something else that happens,
which is when you fill not
in the middle of a band,
not in the middle, but maybe
all the way up to the top.
And there's a gap.
That's a different
kind of material.
So if filling stops somewhere
partially in the band,
in the middle of a
band, if you're filling,
you're counting, and you
didn't go all the way up,
then you have a metal.
But the thing is,
here we've only
talked about one kind of band.
This is the s band.
But every single one of these--
look at this, I can
take a mole of orbitals
and make an s band, like that.
And then, oh, that was 1s.
Here's 2s.
And look at this, I can take the
p electrons and make a p band.
2p band.
I can do this with
every single--
2s, 1s, right?
So depending on a
bunch of factors,
these bands could
look different.
What does it depend on?
So this is-- the way these
bands are organized, right,
we know now that
these orbitals will
come together like I've drawn
there and there and form bands.
What is the difference
between these?
Did they overlap, maybe?
Are they very far in energy?
These things depend on atom--
depends on the atom and the
bonding and the structure.
How do those bands look?
Well, it depends.
And we'll be talking
about some examples.
But for now, I want to focus
on that filling thing again.
What happens if I--
if I fill this 1s up to
half way, it's a metal.
If I keep filling,
keep adding electrons,
and I fill this up
halfway, it's a metal.
But if I stop filling,
you know, if I fill this
and then I fill this, and then
there's some space in energy
and I didn't fill any
more, that's not a metal.
That's not a metal.
So if there's a gap--
so there can be gaps between
bands, which I just showed you.
That's between an
s and a p band.
And then the filling
determines the properties.
And they're so important.
They're so important.
So let's talk about that.
I want to talk about these.
What we're going to
do is we're talking
about semiconductors today
and Wednesday, and metals
on Friday.
And we're going to see it
through the vantage point
of these electronic levels.
And then next week, we'll
see it through the vantage
point of atoms.
So, if you have a gap between--
well, you always have
gaps, the question,
again, comes to filling.
If the filling stops--
I want to define this
very important-- so
if the filling stops,
then you have this highest
occupied level.
So let's suppose
I have filling--
this is some band.
And this is some band.
And this is unoccupied.
So unoccupied by electrons.
This is fully
occupied by electrons.
So what's going to happen?
Well, first of all, let's
just get some terms.
The last band that I filled,
the last band that I filled,
is called the valence band.
Valence band.
And we use vb for short.
And the first band
that I don't fill
is called the conduction band.
And as we talk more
about these materials,
you will see why
they're called that.
Conduction band.
But for now, just trust
me in the labeling.
So the conduction band
and the valence band
depend on the filling.
Because again, it's, you
know, it's where I filled to.
Now, the top level, the very,
very top level out of these 10
to the 24 level, that very
top one has a special name.
It's the vb maximum.
That makes sense, right?
It's the top valence
band, or the vbn.
And the one down here
also has a special name,
it's the cb minimum, or cbm.
So the valence band maximum
and the conduction band minimum
are, you know, it tells
you, if you think about it,
it tells you if you
subtracted those energies
between those parts
of the band, you'd
get the distance and energy
between the two bands.
So the conduction band
minimum is this energy level
here and the valence
band maximum energy is--
Now remember, valence electro--
it's called the valence band.
It makes sense because
valence electrons, remember,
are those ones, as we talked
about with Louis, where you've
got kind of the bonding and
the action and the chemistry
happening.
And so this is
that top most state
of the top most valence band.
This is the valence
band top most state.
And there's one more definition
we got to know about.
This is why we're
setting this up,
which is that that energy
difference here, oh, that
is really important.
So the energy of the
conduction band minimum,
minus the energy of the
valence band maximum,
is equal to something called
the bandgap, energy gap.
It's the band gap.
This is an extremely important
property of materials,
the electronic band gap.
What is the energy difference
between the highest
occupied electrons and the
lowest unoccupied electrons?
That's what we're talking about.
So if that filling,
if that distance--
OK, so here's an
element, carbon,
in the diamond structure.
And just-- purple is filled
and not purple is not filled.
So you know that that's
the connection band.
And that's the valence band.
And the band gap, which
we've just defined here,
is the energy difference
between those.
And for diamond,
it's really large.
For diamond, it's really large.
So you can see that, in
fact, the gap is over--
if we converted this
to electron-volts,
is more than five
electron-volts.
Now, I mentioned
thermal energy in answer
to the question about water.
And room temperature--
so room temperature,
the energy of room temperature,
if you think about temperature
as an energy of like vibrational
motion, and you can do that.
You use something called
the Boltzmann constant
and you can get what the
room temperature energy is.
And it's something like
0.025 electron-volts.
Seems pretty small.
So the point is, if that's the
energy, the thermal energy I
have at room temperature,
then if my bandgap is so much
larger than that, is
so much larger than
that, it means those electrons
are always going to be stuck.
They're never going to,
even in some accident,
have enough thermal energy
to come up and be excited.
We'll talk about this later.
So they're really stuck.
And if an electron is
in the valence band,
it can't move very well.
It can't move-- it's kind
of stuck in those bonds.
It's kind of stuck
in those bonds.
And so here, if there is
electrons all stuck here,
and they never have a
chance to go up here
where they can
travel freely, this
is really going to
be an insulator.
This is not going to carry
electrons through the material.
So that's an insulator.
When you have a very
large bandgap like that,
we call that an insulator.
OK, but see if we compare--
and this is
interesting, you're just
going down in the periodic
table if you compare diamond
to silicon to germanium.
Well, see, what happens is
the bandgap gets smaller.
I'm still filling them all the
way up to the top of a band.
So I'm not a metal.
If I'm a metal, it's because
my filling stopped somewhere
in the middle of the band.
I'm not a metal.
I'm a semi conductor
and not an insulator.
And the reason I'm
a semi conductor
is that my bandgap
is kind of small
enough so that electrons
can kind of jump from here
up to there, sometimes.
Sometimes.
That's why it's called
a semi conductor.
They kind of conduct electrons.
So the electron can get
up to the conduction
band in a semiconductor more
easily than an insulator.
And that's why it can conduct
electricity much better
than an insulator, many, many,
many orders of magnitude.
But the way that we have
talked about getting
electrons excited,
getting electrons excited,
is with light.
And we can do that
for solids, too.
We can do the same
thing for solids.
And so if I plot the
absorption, if I take a solid
and I shine a light
on it, there's
something called the absorption
coefficient, which is really
just a measure of how
far down into the solid
did that light have to go
before some electron got excited
by it?
How well does it-- well,
OK, different solids
can absorb electrons
differently.
But the main point is, if
I plot that versus energy
for something like silicon, the
bandgap of silicon is 1.1 ev,
so that's what it would
look like for silicon
because you know--
this should be wavelength.
Because you know-- because
as you get to lower--
so you know that above--
it's exactly like for atoms.
If I shine light, like
remember the Bohr model,
if I shine light on an atom that
has enough energy to promote it
up, then it can go.
But the difference here is
that for silicon, for silicon,
that's right there,
for silicon there's
this big empty
space with no bands.
It's just like the atom.
When there's no states, I
cannot have an electron there.
I'm stuck.
So the electron can be
here or it can be here.
And so the light, the
energy of the light,
has to be at least the
bandgap to get it up.
At least the bandgap
to get it up.
So what that means
is that if I had--
so, why does this go to zero
with increasing wavelength?
What it means is that if my
valence band looks like this
and my conduction
band looks like this,
and now my light is coming
and I want to take an electron
and promote it up.
Well, it cannot be--
the electron cannot exist
inside the band gap.
There is no states there.
It's just like we
talked about with atoms.
But now we've got almost
infinite states here,
no states there.
And then again we start
with infinite places
where it can be.
What that means is that
if I shine light on it,
the only way silicon, the only
way it can absorb this light
is if the light has energy
greater than the band gap,
or wavelength less
than the bandgap.
That's why I drew it that way.
So it goes to
zero-- so it's going
to absorb in wavelength
up to a certain point.
And then if I go
higher in wavelength,
those are energies
that are too small.
It's going to try to absorb here
but there's nowhere to absorb
to, so it can't.
But if it has enough
energy, oh, look at this.
This is also different.
I could absorb here
or here or here.
I can take all those
higher energies
and absorb light
kind of continuously,
unlike in the atom
where it could only
be the level to hop you from
n equals 2 to n equals 4.
But here I have an almost
continuous set of states,
except in the band gap,
where I have no states.
So that's what the absorption
would look like for silicon.
And if you look at the bandgap,
this very, very important
quantity, there is carbon.
There's diamond.
There's silicon.
There's germanium.
And you can see that as you
go to heavier and heavier
elements, you change the gap.
And you can understand
this from what
you know about the
electron levels in atoms.
Because in an atom, remember,
if I get heavier and heavier,
those electrons all the way on
the outer edges of the atom,
they're more weakly
bonded to the atom.
They're weaker and
weaker and weaker.
So the energy is
higher and higher.
Remember, so instead of being
these deeper energy levels that
have more bonding, more energy
in them, lower in energy,
they're less and less energy.
So you can imagine,
now, that those
are what you're starting with.
Those are what you're
starting with, these.
Right these are the atom levels
that you're starting with.
So if you're going to make
your atom have electrons that
are more weakly bound with
energies that are higher,
that aren't as deep and
don't have as much distance
between them in the
energy landscape,
then the gaps will get smaller.
Now, that is a
very simple picture
of why the gaps get smaller.
It happens to work
for this column.
So if you look at
this-- and some people
would even call this
a metal because that's
such a small gap, but I like
to call it a semiconductor.
But if your gap is zero,
if you're band gap is zero,
it means there is no gap.
So by definition, you're
in the middle of a band.
You're somewhere in
the middle of a band.
And if you're in the middle
of a band, you're a metal.
You didn't fill that
band all the way up.
But if you filled it
up and then there's
a little gap between
you and the next level,
then you're a semiconductor.
Or if it's much greater,
like greater than three
electron volts, 3 and
1/2 electron volts,
then you're an insulator.
Now, so you can
imagine now why--
so as the interactions
get stronger,
you can imagine those
distances can get larger.
And so you could have
larger and larger gaps,
which can explain this trend.
But as I said before,
where did I put it,
it depends, not just on the atom
and the original energy levels,
but on how those bond together.
And we'll talk about
that on Wednesday.
And it also depends on
the structure, which
we'll talk about next week.
So it's not just
as simple as that
but you can understand
basic trends this way
for some of the columns.
OK, we'll get to that on Friday.
Now, the goodie bag gives
you a way to probe this.
So what's in the goodie bag?
The goodie bag has a way
of measuring conductivity.
Now, I just told you that you
cannot get connectivity unless
you have electrons that
are able to make this jump,
to make this jump.
They've got to be able to
go up from the valence band
to the conduction band.
If they don't do that,
they're not free.
They're stuck in these bonds.
You've got to get them free so
they can roam around and not
be stuck in this
bond or that bond.
This measures that.
This measures whether electrons
are in the conduction band.
You've also got some
LEDs and some LEDs.
And this is a
critical piece here.
Why do you have
two kinds of LEDs?
Because on the one
hand, what you're doing,
I'm giving you a way
to excite electrons.
So I'm giving you a way to
actually promote electrons.
So you've got 10 to the 24
electrons in this valence band.
This would be the vb and
this would be the cb.
And what you're doing
is you're shining light
with different frequencies,
which means different energies.
That's what the right
hand side gives you.
It gives you different
energies of the photons.
So you have a way,
now, of shining energy
on a semiconductor.
And that's the second piece.
The semiconductor
is what an LED is.
It's a semiconductor.
If LEDs were insulators,
they wouldn't work.
And if they were metals,
Because the way an LED works
is actually just the opposite.
Here, I'm shining light so
that an electron gets promoted
and I can measure that
with my voltmeter.
But I could also put
electrons in with a current.
That gets them up
here and then they
drop down and emit a photon.
That's what an LED is.
That's what an LED is,
it's just the reverse.
And so what I've
given you on the left
are different semiconductors.
Because you see, just like
a different-- you know,
if I'm running current through
like I am on the right,
you see, those are
different colors.
That means that I must
have different gaps.
You know that.
You know that
already from the work
we did with Bohr and the
color or frequency of light
that you can get out of
different transitions.
But it's the same here.
Did an electron-- you know,
did I put an electron up here
and then it fell down
and gave off some lambda?
That lambda has to equal
the difference between the--
it just equals the band gap.
It equals the band gap because
the electron was put up
to here in the cbm and then
it drops down to the vbm
and it emits a photon.
That's what's happening
on the right hand side.
But see, you've also got,
on the left hand side,
you've got sensors because
it's just LEDs on the left.
But if I hook those
up, if I hook those up
to the volt meter,
well, I'm hooking up
a semiconductor to a voltmeter.
So I'm hooking this up and I'm
reading, is there any current.
And the answer in
a dark room is no,
unless you make it
really, really hot.
Don't, because you have to
go to very high temperatures.
Well, what if I shine
light on this now?
Well, if I shine light
that has the right energy
to put electrons up in
the cbm from the vbm,
then I'll read something
on the voltmeter.
So by giving you different
LEDs on the left,
I'm giving you
different band gaps.
You have in your hands different
semiconductor band gaps.
And by reading whether there
are electrons in here or not,
you can tell what frequency
of light I shined on them.
So they're both emitters
of photons and detectors
of photons.
And it all comes
together because you
have a semiconductor, which
happens because you took 10
to the 24 states, you
put them together,
you had gaps between them,
and you filled all the way up
to one of those gaps, and that
gap was around 1 or 2 electron
volts.
We will pick this up on
Friday and go further--
I mean on Wednesday,
on Wednesday.